hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
firma im video ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht's gut ich bin gerade in berlin bzw
schon ein bisschen außerhalb also ich
wusste jetzt nicht das so weit außerhalb
ist aber gehört das doch zu
berlin-brandenburg ich bin heute hier
weil daniel patrick und zwar habe ich ja
damals war bei rtl retouren profis
mitgemacht habe ich darüber
kennengelernt beziehungsweise nur so
flüchtig also wir haben uns nie gesehen
und ich dachte mir wenn ich jetzt schon
mal in berlin bin dann komme ich mal bei
denen vorbei weil die machen auch super
viele retouren und ich glaube es wird
ganz spannend und interessant wie hier
auch direkt mal was ausgesucht was wir
zusammen jetzt da ich uns mal anschauen
werden dafür dann ist da haben wir
einfach mal rein gemacht gucken oder
macht eine pause
alles wird ja nicht mal kennt so werden
ebenso wie hier im bereich der goldenen
retouren hand weil ich mit dem
gabelstapler eigentlich abholen aber das
ist alles hier dein reich ist unser
erreichen genau hier verwerten wir jeden
monat knapp 100 paletten europas also
ich muss sagen wir nicht so paletten
höre dann geht man also weiß ich ja
schon bei mir also leute für euch jetzt
noch mal kurz zur erklärung ich war in
berlin oder bin grad wie man sieht immer
noch in berlin und ich dachte mir was
auf wenn ich jetzt hier am start bin
komme ich mal vorbei weiß ja oder wären
wir schon öfter mal geschrieben ihr habt
super viele retouren und auch so keine
ahnung was ist hat meist was wir hier in
namhafte retouren von großen firmen
liegen direkt selten ist jawohl wir
jungen sind ja
ich will mich dort wie sie diese straßen
menschen die immer so welche frauen auf
der straße das gut wie bist du schon mal
fremdgegangen
wo du meinst 70 paletten kommenden monat
kommen jeden monat jan dahin haben wir
noch einen riesen wand wo noch ganz
viele retouren warten auf mädchen noch
alle bearbeitet werden müssen und ich
darf mir jetzt für 600 euro eine palette
auswählen und die darf dann hier
auspacken und du schickst mir dann
einfach zu ok so machen wir das und ja
dann bin ich mal gespannt und ich hoffe
dass es interessant wird es bei mir ist
aber wichtig was wir am ende vom
warenwert erzielen die sagen einfach wir
machen das jetzt einfach so und leute
bleibt dran das ist eine wahre genau das
ist von einem sehr großen händler auf
sogar den namen sagen ja es ist nicht
über aber es geht in diese richtung ok
ja alles gut europa leute 600 euro genau
wie verkauft so dass schon alles so
normalerweise habe ich zwei kunden die
das thema komplett abgekauft haben wie
man will immer ein bisschen mehr am
leben jetzt verkauft die paletten
einzeln und es macht einfach mehr sind
und da haben mehr leute
wir warten
nur eine aus würde ich sagen also die
könnte ich das auch für sechs
unternehmen und praktisch zu kaufen aber
ich kann dir auch ganz ehrlich sagen
meisten dieser fernseher die kriege die
haben alle größere defekte ich glaube da
wird also würde ich jetzt nicht sechs
sondern euro zwei mädchen handelt ohne
fernsehen paletten fünf fernseher drauf
sind maximal pro fernseher 30 euro
jährlich
du kannst dich so günstigen du kannst
kam dass da einer drin ist er vielleicht
nicht startet dann machst du ein
bisschen was repariert es in der warnung
davon hast ja nie so richtig geld damit
aber allein die ressorts insofern sind
doch schon mehr wert als 30 euro ist
richtig dass oftmals eine fernbedienung
drin die alleine schon 50 euro wert hat
und das den ganzen preis wieder raus
hält können wir es so machen dass du mir
wirklich so eine palette zu schickst
einfach dass man ja also wenn du da
müssen wir die nicht hier aufmachen dann
mach ich dir lieber in meinem büro auf
dann sagen wir direkt was nimmst du hier
ich will mich ja nicht abziehen sachen
guten preis und für die eine palette
fernseher ja 120 20 euro trinkgeld okay
dann kriegst du mir die zum edition
kommt ja auch noch drauf ihr habt das
jetzt nicht mitbekommen da vorne steht
schon der palette die habe ich mir jetzt
ausgesucht und die packen jetzt zusammen
aus und dann schauen wir mal ob das so
ist wenn die leute denken jetzt wo ich
habe bestimmt eine palette rausgesucht
die ihm richtig gut muss sagen ich
selber partie gar nicht mehr die haben
jetzt sechs mitarbeiter jemand
tatsächlich die paletten packen und kann
auch sein das jetzt scheiße ist und du
hast sehr enttäuschend ist kann es
genießen aber wir schauen einfach mal
sagen wenn wir die kamera ab und dann
machen wir das okay leute dann ist
sofort der eine palette dann mach ich
dir jetzt auch patrick auch vor der
kamera dazu sagt er verletzt ist okay
und ich will noch mal wirklich betonen
sie haben sie jetzt extra keine
besondere palette irgendwie hin
begleitet sondern noch mal warum nicht
die nächste dann ja okay ich bringe
spannen leute und wir fangen jetzt
einfach mal an leider direkt sagen das
ist alles so zeugt und ist so aus dem
baumarkt mäßig oder
das klingt wirklich wir wissen wirklich
nicht ob du es glaubst und ich glaub ich
da wissen wirklich nicht was selber
drauf ist aber für mich sieht das hier
alles so aus als könnte man das zum
beispiel so bauhaus kaufen oder so oder
stimmt das nicht es stimmt
dass wir die marke kann ich auf jeden
fall da hatte ich schon mal in einer
anderen staubsauger eg habt ihr auch oft
wahre wie komplett ungeschickt ist jetzt
drin ja die gibt es war aber die ist
auch ich dachte es heißt eigentlich ist
alles b ware aber mittlerweile habe ich
so viele erfahrungen und auch sachen und
perfekt ich muss mal ganz kurz meine
apps ohne und das einmal 139 euro wenn
sie funktioniert das ist auf jeden fall
keinen schüler anfangen wo playmobil
hier aber ihr müsst ja später das alles
wieder zusammenbauen um was
habt ihr noch vielleicht so einen tisch
limango
das ist die marke das oder daher kommt
das kann ich gar nicht hier hinten was
hier hinten sieht auch noch interessant
aus also das ist wirklich ganz neues
gebiet für mich ne dinge an naja ich ach
so und das baut man oben drauf könnte
ich auch eigentlich in meine wohnung hin
so sieht das dann gemeinsam
preis ist jetzt hier eingeblendet so
dann haben wir hier wahrscheinlich
nochmal diese uhr ja geil nicht verkehrt
medizinschrank bedruckt medizinschrank
weiß ja kann ich meine ganzen heroin und
so
super teppich laufen teppich gar nicht
so schlecht ich glaube meine eltern
können auch teppiche gebrauchen
vielleicht die scheiße los und habe ich
mir angetan wurde
vielleicht ist dann ja noch iphone
versteck
spielen
kann ich mich noch dran ändern hatte ich
früher auch das kann man aufstellen dann
kann man also ich hab es leider nicht
kennst du die marke bs
manager nicht nicht für sechs kinder 12
34 25
191 brettspiel hat jetzt keinen
besonderen werden aber hier oben sich
direkten kissen oder ein mann ist auf
den kisten parser kissen in weiße hat
sich direkt stimmt ja die kisten da sind
echte unbequemen bilder waren
was würdest du schätzen was also kann es
jetzt mal raus und schätze ist dass hin
waren
ohne regen dusche erwarte ich habe es
jetzt erst gesehen ich wünsche mir
wirklich in meiner wohnung schon seit
jahren regen dusche geil das ist weil
die marke cannondale die kostet doch
bestimmt so 250 oder 23 dass die
bestimmt wenn ich jetzt schon überlegen
bereich ist das steht jetzt die palette
für sechs mal verkauft habe ehrlich also
ich finde das ist eine tolle dusche und
die werde ich auf jeden fall zu hause
mal ausprobieren okay jetzt so langsam
kommen wir jedoch noch viel drauf also
wir haben ja jetzt bestimmt schon 500
oder 600 neuwert na ja also wir müssen
sie gleich wieder zusammenbauen die
palette und dann film ist alles noch mal
von der anderen seite
weitergeht sei das aber schwer den baum
die haben auch instagram facebook in
tourist service in creme melden kann
sein dass das schon kaputt ist oder
wunderschöne aber ich falle ja auch
immer zu hause da wenn ich david
auspacke immer das messer aber
ihr könnt mir eine zwischenzeit sagen er
macht auch youtube nicht genau wir sind
aktiv auf youtube ist dem flohmarkt
werden unterwegs gewesen den man
schnäppchen bin jetzt aber auf jeden
fall ein paar mehrere zu youtube kann
man euch finden und ich verlinke euch
das mal leute also wenn ihr euch dafür
interessiert so ähnliche sachen wie ich
auch mache dann schaut bei den jungs
gerne vorbei teller guck mal eigentlich
gar nicht schlecht könnte ich auch
meiner oma zum beispiel werden könnt ihr
euch aus mit tellern was sie so kosten
ich habe nur die hochzeit ist die villa
verkaufen
kellerhals warum nach noch mehr regen
dusche oder jetzt keine regen das ist
doch auch nur eine kleine mini
regenduschen teleskop buseck prämie und
wenn die marke kenne ich druck dollar
das heißt nix also ich glaube die hälfte
der wahl kann ich direkt hier lassen
passt alles gar nicht bei mir ins büro
rein den grill mit kapselmaschine von
nespresso
ich habe zu hause eine kaffeemaschine
von nespresso und das ist wirklich ein
geiles ding
heute aha alles aber nur schon etwas
älteres modell nespresso wert yonex die
kost bestimmt 200 euro ist notwendig so
komplett zu 20 sollen gar nicht
interessiert
ja eigentlich ganz gut aus oder ist
kaffee drin ich sehe schon die wurde auf
jeden fall schon mal ordentlich benutzt
ja doch ich muss sagen eigentlich wird
von paket für paket das war also ich bin
mir sicher wir haben auf jeden fall
jetzt schon so langsam 1000 euro
erreicht haben wir noch einen spieler
egal langweilig zu bedrucken solar
gartenstädter und den habe ich letztes
jahr meine eltern zu weihnachten
geschenkt da kosten vier stück bei
amazon irgendwie 35 euro
die kriegen einfach dieses jahr noch
mehr die finde ich schön könig
grillabend da und ist könig eine gute
marke
40 euro koste als klo also das heißt der
klodeckel fällt automatisch runter
sind solche klodeckel teuer eine 60
funktion jetzt einfach mal so
geschäftsleute klodeckel keine ahnung
sommer handtuchhalter handel stellen da
sie aber auch ganz cool aussagen ist
moderne ja jetzt kommen wir noch mal die
größeren sachen ist ein grill
haben wir nach so dass so ein
aktenvernichter ne mülleimer
meinst also leute ich weiß ihr könnt sie
wahrscheinlich anmerken ich glaube schon
dass ich hier auf jeden fall jetzt nicht
schlecht welt kommen aber habe mich
jetzt nicht so euphorisieren einfach
aber das ist ja auch alles
meine ich auch nicht böse oder
aber für leute die jetzt ein haus bauen
oder zu ihr haus einrichten des franken
verteilt wobei ich habe auch viele
ältere zuschauer die schreiben manchmal
gab mir die kommentare dass wir so
schöne zuschauer sind schon über 60
jahre alt okay also wenn jemand von
ihnen ein mülleimer haben möchte melden
sie sich was ist da denn standmixer
mehrere gleich heiß dose oder werden
erinnerungen wach diese kaka muss klar
sein wenn dann meistens dann noch
irgendwas was die letzte regierung mit
beißen ist das natürlich nicht so leicht
ich kann euch jetzt gern hier ein
standmixer zeigen aber ich weiß nicht ob
das so sinnvoll weil ich glaube
standmixer hat jeder schon mal gesehen
sagen 69 euro die heiße fritteuse
manchmal eben auch ja die sind doch alle
gleich aus weil man dem tv
alexisbad auch gekommen ist also ich
würd in sonder gebrauchten ist eine
friteuse niemals meine pommes machen
oder eigentlich
aber dass wir fett
drankommen wissen ja auch
eigentlich neue ja das ist ja
okay dann haben wir hier noch dreimal
tablett tisch oder bluetooth super ist
das wenigstens selbst
bewässerungsprojekt ob der sich selber
bewässert
ist aber ein schwerer blumen es ist
wichtig ein wilder blumentopf von klären
t silber alles im hintergrund ja hier
ist ein spiegel aus new york new jersey
around with black rain spieglein an der
wand wer ist der schönste euro was ein
tolles bild das kommt bei mir auf jeden
fall in die küche am schlimmsten finde
ich eigentlich leute die so richtig
hässliche bilder in der wohnung haben
oder bilder die viel zu viele in der
wohnung haben zum beispiel dieser kölner
dom oder eiffelturm von paris ich muss
sagen man kommt auch ganz schön ins
schwitzen hier aber das ja auch
eigentlich gut wenn ihr sowas halt viel
macht dann müsst ihr nicht so viel sport
machen oder so dass gerade ein bisschen
zurückhaltend dass du die maya wandregal
montessori haben wir jetzt das erste mal
anscheinend die marke ball oder
zumindest die kauft at limango
vielleicht ist hier jetzt was richtig
teures intakt sagt
so was wollte schon immer mal haben
legen wir es mal schnell wieder rein und
noch eine frage wenn man jetzt gleich
mal als ich für so paletten interessiert
wenn du sagst du verkaufst dass man
einzelne leute bald meine zuschauer
fragen mich immer alex wo kauft nur die
ganzen retouren und was müssen sie
machen wenn sie sich für ein paar leute
interessieren zwei möglichkeiten wenn
ihr solche paletten kaufen wollt
entweder geht den weg über alle ihr
schreibt die menschheit eine palette
haben dann sagt er mir bescheid das ist
ein großes verbindung oder ihr geht den
direkten weg und schreibt mir dann könnt
ihr auch so eine palette kaufen und es
gibt immer verschiedene themenbereiche
mal so ein bisschen mehr déco möbeln
bisher ein spielzeug alles mögliche kann
oder in mehr lampen ich habe es die
lampen hier wissen wo man zeit für ihre
beratungen noch immer 60
65 65 sein könnte auch nicht
beeinflussen aber es war einmal
na ja so was habe ich auch noch bei mir
im büro rumstehen davon dass einfach
aufweist ich habe schon mal hier geht
das ist
vorsichtig
ach so das ist sonja ist kunst das ist
ein kunstwerk guck mal eigentlich gar
nicht so verkehrt was ist nun das sind
dass papageien oder wie heißt noch mal
mit dem großen schneebällen der hier
sieht aus wie vorher
also ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
das gas also wirklich das geld ist jetzt
also ich finds verkehr jetzt kommen wir
noch zwei dicke kartons ist erst
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal so ein
pelikan das sieht doch erstmal gut aus
sagte hier ist jetzt ein großer doping
überall wohin lampen haben hier sind
laut plan noch mehr lampen led
solarleuchte leider
sagen wir einfach mal das sind acht
lampen drin und jede lampe kostet 20
euro und sagen wir mal 120 euro für alle
lampen und hier drunter sind
wahrscheinlich auch nochmal lampen oder
malaysia alessia italienisch lampen sind
doch immer teurer dann gucken wir mal ob
wir noch mehr lampen angehen und dann
haben wir es geschafft er ist ja
wirklich was anderes kitchen live ich
dachte gerade erst kitchenaid
ehrlich die sind steuern ebt oliven und
wollte schon immer mal ein messer in das
messer ein beil messer brauche ich
wirklich also zu hoffen
ok dann machen wir das hier ist noch mal
hier steht ein extra die auch so ist
auch eine salatschüssel kanada mit drei
salatschüsseln bisher in irgendwelche
aufbewahrungsbehälter und das war es ich
muss sagen an sich vom warenwert glaube
ich ist es in ordnung wenn man
sicherlich einiges mit verdienen wenn
man sich so da jetzt mit auskennt und
dem ist kann ich nicht ich finde es cool
dass ich jetzt hier war und dass ich das
alles mal gesehen habe aber es wird auf
jeden fall schwierig und der
herausforderung mal was neues immer
positiv denken meinst du was ängste was
sich hier so rausholen will also wenn
ich alles ein zu verkaufen hat ich
glaube schon dass man da sicherlich 1000
1400 steht auf dieser kopplung auf jeden
fall der leute trotzdem fielen dann ich
bin trotzdem glücklich weil es glaube
ich ein gutes video geworden danke dass
ich vorbei kommen konnte und auch mal
kennengelernt zu haben und die pflanze
die möchte ich aber noch haben
aber machen wir mit den fans also alles
wieder gutgemacht dank fürs zuschauen
dort gerne mal bei den beiden jungs
vorbei die machen auch coole videos wie
gesagt ähnlich wie bei mir und an die
sich bestimmt noch mal kann haut rein
und einen daumen nach oben da das
natürlich